so first what is observability and why
are we talking about it um
let's start with a little bit of level
setting
so
systems have functional requirements you
know cars
software applications uh functional
requirement is specifying what a system
is supposed to do right so a car for
example transports people from one
location to
another
systems also have non-functional
requirements uh that specify how the
system is supposed to be or defining it
in other words defining its qualities so
comfort uh or safety uh specifically for
this example that this protecting the
options from harm during transport is
one of the qualities that you want from
a car
and these are just one of the many
abilities of the modern software and
engineering
applications these days there's
usability scalability testability uh you
know readability maintainability
availability all of these abilities
and
observability is just now one of these
abilities right and applications
different applications have
different scales for how how much of
that quality
needs to be
present in that application for example
maybe the blue app needs to have a
scalability uh
twice as much of a green app on
this example
vernon robles the the cto of aws
actually explained observability really
well in one of his uh keynotes for
reinvent in uh late 2020 so i'll i'll
play his video and kind of let him
describe observability
when we talked about the history of
dependability i mentioned systems theory
a related field of data
the systems control theory
it has been crucial in building many
dependable industrial and other systems
the most important pioneer in this field
was professor rudolf kalman
in 1960 he defined concepts such as
whether a system was controllable
and observable or actually inaudible
to be observable
is something we know as software
engineers all too well how can we infer
the internal state of a system
from its outputs
this can be functional outputs like
voltage and amperage of the turbines
or non-functional output like the
turbine temperature sensors or
rotation speed measurements
and this is what we try to achieve
with the observability property of a
dependable system
how can we infer the internal state of
our digital systems from its outputs
which can include both functional
requires from apicals for example or
request to other parts of the system
from non-functional information
that we collect from other means
so inferring the operational state of a
system based on its outputs
you've got your inputs and your system
which is opaque and then you have
outputs which you can see measure and
analyze
and observability has a quality scale
itself right so just like uh scalability
or maintainability there's on on one end
it can be you know your your outputs
leave the system still completely opaque
you can't see into it or on the other
hand you have excellent observability
and you your outputs uh render the
system completely transparent you can
see everything that's going on within
your application in your system
so
to kind of uh
to illustrate this we're going to time
travel back to the to the early
2000s uh with a very very simple php app
uh maybe this php app just took an image
uh extracted uh urls or
metadata from the image and um outputted
a simple page that allowed you to see
those uh metadata and attributes of that
image
well if you have uh if you had you know
things like just server monitoring your
cpu and memory of your application of
the host of where your application was
running and then maybe you added a
little bit of the apache server
application logs to see the amount of
traffic or the
requests per second
and the amount of errors
you're actually maybe doing pretty well
for this simple simple php app you know
your observability quality scale might
be toward the higher end for something
this simple
why
is because well this is a very simple
simple application and
early on you know 15 10 years ago there
was mostly identical years of experience
through the entire application stack so
all of your visitors essentially could
be thought of of you know the the same
uh the same kind of experience you know
there's no individual in application
experience that was different from one
visitor to another
and if you threw in a little bit of
testing acro above and beyond this uh
simple server and maybe apache log
monitoring you're actually doing pretty
well and you're seeing you know a very
well
um or very very high coverage of your
stack
it's because there were limited pathways
to kind of interact with your
application
traditional monitoring is very low
dimensional we treated all of these
experiences is the same you know we
could measure um
and it lacked the contextual differences
that separate
the one app experience from another
and now let's talk about why monitoring
is not observability uh again with uh
verner vogels the cto of aws
classical monitoring deals with two
questions
what is broken
and why is it work
monitoring uses a predefined set of
metrics and logs to determine known
values
in general with monitoring and alarming
you can't predict
when things are fail
you can only take action when they do
it is why we used to call people who
wanted to be systems operators and not
engineers
the generators here at
sugar city are extremely complex
it is only likely that the operator of
the dashboard
knew how to repair it
when something went wrong
but they did know when the sounding
alarm and gauges moved to where they
were supposed to go
as systems continue to increase in
complexity it is impossible
to put every important metric for that
system on a single dashboard every user
watches
think about everything that goes into a
modern application
there are metrics for the servers
containers and functions that you're
managing your application has counters
and mods for all the work is doing you
may have anywhere from thousands to
millions of customers
all which have data about what they're
doing
and how they interact with your
application
it is impossible to put all of this on a
dashboard for the euro watches
to define alerts for each of these
metrics to tell you
when they're going on spec
at amazon we've been on a 25-year
journey to improve the processes of
managing our systems
and we've long left the notion that this
monitoring was sufficient to manage our
systems
we've embarked on a holistic approach to
operations
from collecting
massive amounts of data
and logs
to how we analyze them to how we solve
and talk about problems when we do have
and this is what observability is all
about
how can you make sure you have the data
the tools and the mechanisms
to quickly resolve problems in a
fundamental way
how can we
without reaching into the system
in the first internal state
for the data that we have
and amazon our most important drivers
have always been
customer-centric
find end results problems before they
impact customers
understand the impact on your customers
when you couldn't prevent it
and fix the problem
so that it never happens
again
so he made a a really important point uh
here is you know monitoring is not
observability and with the most complex
apps these days or with the the
applications these days growing more and
more complex
more
services interoperability more uh
individual user
unique interactions with an application
you can no longer fit your monitoring
and the the amount
of data that you need for observability
on dashboards
systems evolve from simple to complex
this is true for applications today it's
also true for you know telephone think
about the 1900s candlestick telephone
right
it had different requirements and
different um
complexities than say
the modern smartphone of the 2020s right
different usability scalability all of
the leds were different through these
generations of telephone
evolution
it's true for automobiles
and for software
uh you know you can't imagine
these these software facebook or google
calendar or twitter
existing today as they were you know 15
10 uh even less years ago uh you know
with the amount of features and
interactivity and infinite stroke
scrolling um ai applied to
feeds all of these different things that
make these applications just more and
more complex
and complexly like entropy just
increases right
it's true for phones true for
applications
so monitoring is actually now you know a
subset of observability
in that modern or in that
early candlestick telephone uh with your
traditional say basic monitoring of that
system you might actually have been
doing pretty well with your you know
observability um
as as we've talked about it today of
what it encompasses to make sure that
you can observe all of the performance
qualities of that system but that's just
not true today not true of uh the
smartphones um and not true for for
applications with traditional monitoring
for
again using the example of the thp app
from the early uh 2000s you know with
our uh server cpu memory and then apache
logs it might have been pretty excellent
back then
um those those limited amount of metrics
and um
uh throughput metrics in server metrics
don't cover your observability needs for
a modern application today
so
everybody visiting your php app you know
15 10 years ago
never really was the same user
experience but it was often a reasonable
approximation
now it's
just not reasonable at all modern apps
are just much richer offer a wider
variety of user experiences it's it's
different for essentially everybody
using uh applications these days once
you log in or start interacting with a
personal account on these modern
applications there are so many different
ways that the application can behave or
respond or
execute different things and call
various
apis or external services that are just
totally unique
for each individual's situation within
these modern applications
and so monitoring really is the tip of
the observability iceberg right
traditional monitoring is
low dimensional and low cardinality
uh
things like aggregated metrics or
summary statistics are the things that
we used for monitoring uh up until
recently
and that sits just on a huge iceberg
of contextual data high dimensional high
cardinality data that you need in order
to achieve true observability
for
example another a request latency
histogram
uh showing two two peaks one around the
uh one second mark and then another
around the say a seven or eight second
mark so so two peaks along this and you
you kind of get that distribution of
this
aggregated metric for the request
latency histogram
well if you add some contextual data to
that and you attach these tags for this
metrics that we can break it out and
get extra dimensions based on whether
it's a desktop or mobile or whether the
location is uh in a certain city if you
attach that
geographical and um platform information
now you can break this out and start to
see what the composition of that overall
chart was
and we can see that if we actually go
down through the desktop and then down
lower to the bottom charts of lowe's
matrix we can see that that second
uh that second peak actually matches the
new york city and boston and dc area
for desktop users so we know that that's
likely the uh problem area for this
latency histogram on the higher end
the good thing is
you know with with um modern monitoring
we are starting to bubble these up right
we're starting to bubble a little bit of
this contextual data up so it can be a
bit more um give you a bit more
automatic insight into kind of
what those metrics may be
that's just a few dimensions so um you
know people have been kind of taking the
approach of well
we can handle that we can just add this
contextual data to our to our metrics
and um we'll
we'll just make more dashboards and put
those more on more dashboards and let's
just add more monitoring for these
dimensions right
and that's just more that's just more
monitoring that's just more dashboards
right you're going to have a problem of
you're going to have just more and more
dashboards growing
as you add more context and it's just as
verner said it's impossible to observe
your systems using the monitoring
metrics and dashboards that we've used
up to this point
so how do we achieve the
excellent side of observability making
our systems and
applications as transparent as possible
when you read about observability or the
traditional pillars of uh monitoring
you'll read about
metrics traces and laws uh we'd like to
think of them as uh these these four um
different um
constituent elements of observability
which we we define as logs metrics spans
and events
logs are your traditional logs
but they include the attributes and
context identifiers attached to those
logs as well so you can correlate the
logs um these highly specific debugging
tools in your logs to the matrix spans
of events that happen elsewhere
uh metrics are your aggregated summary
statistics that we're used to in
traditional monitoring um but
including
the attributes and context identifiers
again these are the things that are
going to sew and thread the logs and
metrics and spans and events all
together to kind of compose your
observability system
uh spans are time span tag locations
within services their code or your stack
to allow you to know at what point in
time you were or the request was
uh when that specific uh
period of time happened
and then uh events are the the discrete
individual events at a point in time
that that were encountered within a time
span again with just as many attributes
and context identifiers as we can attach
to these
um
the kind of analogy here is
these constituent elements of logs
metrics spans and events aren't
necessarily
um
[Music]
super interesting
by themselves or useful by themselves
but together they compose
the um elements and molecules and
eventually the planets and universe
that exist so
these are the constituent elements of
observability
and the context and attributes are the
key to observability
so an extremely simplified example of
what
observability may be within the context
of application performance tracing
so let's say a user triggers an action
on the front end of your application
you'll start
a trace or a span here that's
automatically generated from your
observability instrumentation
and you can attach these identifiers to
this contextual um information to this
trace so that we can identify maybe the
front end uh version or the page route
that that's that this user took
even the the user metadata like their id
or their the product plan that they're
on which device they're using the
location are they in chicago are they in
boston are they in dc where where are
they located
and that frontline call then makes the
back-end call on your uh servers hosted
on your your infrastructure and you can
attach back-end metadata to that so uh
which endpoint was hit which post it was
which container id which uh kubernetes
cluster things like that
and that back end api call makes a
database call right and then we can
create a metrics off of that we can
maybe say okay we want to count how many
times this database call was actually
made and service that as the summary
statistic later on
and then that database query is
eventually executed on on the uh the
database uh over the database connection
and we can tell when the connection was
actually established and make that a
point in time events
if that database query returns we can
then log that as
with specific database call information
we could log different
different information about that
database call depending on the time it
took and things like this so now we've
made
a metric counter metric an event in the
log
and maybe we make an external service
call this could be a
api call between your microservices
within your individual uh infrastructure
or it could be you know a third-party
hosted um
api call from any of the increasingly uh
sas or um
third-party vendor hosted service that
makes the
api endpoints exposed for
services that are critical for your
application to to execute
so that external service execution
returns we can log that as well
we've made the response and we send that
back to the back end and that goes back
to the front end
but maybe the front end front-end action
is not completely done yet and it needs
to make another back-end call right so
we've still got that level front end
action with the identifier the action
identifier that is actually attached to
all of these
other calls the first back-end api call
the the next database call the database
query the external services
and in addition now we're making a
second backing call page maybe to load a
paginated
list of of data on your application
and again we make a database query we we
record the connection established there
and that returns the uh amount of
items and we make a count
metric out of that as well
and then maybe it loads uh preloads
maybe the second page of paginated
results and we can thread all of this
through
and connect all of these different
uh
events back to that single triggered
front-end action so
very highly contextual
and
correlated
now distributed tracing in this in this
instance
and then we can log the action outcome
metadata on that as well
so you can see that context connects
everything
and
the the more context the more
data we can attach to these events and
these uh traces these logs and these
metrics
allows us to correlate
all of this information together and
allows us to search and
surface insights about all of these
related events
and until recently
you could do this
to an extent either buy it from a vendor
a large vendor typically and or you
could try to build it yourself and a lot
of it from scratch it was expensive
either way
so there's two
there's two key trends changing that uh
the first one is cost effective and
performing data storage and compute
resources for high cardinality big data
the second one is open source
observability apis and sdks and tooling
implemented collectively collectively
with broad support from the community
and vendors
so we'll talk about the second one first
open telemetry is a fairly new project
it's been getting a ton of vendor
support and community support and is
emerging as a new lingua franca of of
observability
open telemetry defines a cross-language
specification for how
apis in the sdks responsible for
collecting and configuring
the
telemetry and instrumentation of
languages and frameworks and libraries
should be done uh it allows
the
standards to be applied
in a standard fashion across
all the major languages that then
have their own libraries written
to adhere to these specs the api and sdk
libraries are written in the native
language of these uh
programming languages
that
implement this specification the same
way so that we have cross-functional
cross-language apis and sdks that all
handle the data in a standard way
and then there's the open telemetry
collection and agnostic export formats
that allow these languages in the apis
and sdks to send that data to a
collector and further send that data on
to
multiple backends whether it be uh your
your own destination uh your open source
tools uh zipkin or jager
and additionally to third parties like
scout
so scout application performance
observability
as we're evolving into uh is built on uh
open telemetry and
some facts about open telemetry the top
active cloud it's the now the top active
cloud uh native computing federation
project behind only kubernetes
it's backed by over 130 companies
including the big ones like aws google
microsoft facebook splunk and scout it's
integrated directly into open source
projects and cloud native stacks instead
of injected into them
and it's simple to use with extensive
ability to customize instrumentation
specific to your environment
and so that's great right so
now that there's this vendor agnostic
and kind of standard um
way to apply this
uh telemetry and using these apis that
are that are defined through the
openflow machine specification
and available for uh open source
libraries and packages and framework
maintainers um
there used to be this wall in between
observability instrumentation like scout
would write itself and apply as an
outside-in patch to these libraries and
frameworks in order to gather telemetry
data
um
we're kind of breaking down that wall
and the the package maintainers they
would have never we could have never
approached a package maintainer like
rails and say hey rails we want to put
um scout apms observability
instrumentation into the rails framework
and committed to upstream to the rails
project there's no way that they would
have applied that vendor-specific
telemetry into the rails project
but now
bringing down this kind of wall in
between those with the vendor agnostic
apis and
specifications it's now more acceptable
and
more
libraries and packages and frameworks
should be more
willing to incorporate this
open telemetry
into their libraries and frameworks so
that's built natively into these
libraries and frameworks instead of
injected by vendors
after the fact
so let's talk a little bit about the
components of open telemetry
there's the specification which defines
um kind of how things should be laid out
it makes the standards of what we're
talking about and naming and operations
and then there's the api uh which is the
application program interface that
library maintainers and framework
containers will use
and then there's sdks which are
meant to be used by the end user or
within your end application
[Music]
in order to configure and use open
supplementary within your application
and then there's also the collector
which is a way a means of collecting
this this uh data sent from these sdks
uh to the collector uh as kind of a
proxy of either further
aggregation or processing of this open
symmetry data and sending it to the back
ends the collector though is is optional
so the specification the specification
actually defines how the apis should
behave it defines the standard naming of
the stability guarantees the separations
of concern the communication protocols
and the data formats and the
compatibility uh the backwards
compatibility uh guarantees that that it
makes for the api in the sdk etc
semantic conventions are just the way
that we name things this could be things
like um container id or a
cloud region like what do we call it the
key value pieces of these where we can
find that contextual information in a
standard way
that we can connect all the logs metrics
traces
and
our logs metrics spans and events
together to kind of weave them into
an observability picture
sliced and diced through any
possible combination that we want to
investigate
and then otlp is a
transport it's called the open telemetry
line protocol it's a transport protocol
that defines how the communication
between the
sdk and the collector should behave
the api component of the open telemetry
project
is um
the purpose is to develop an api library
in every major language to be used by
library and framework developers in
order to add instrumentation natively
into the library or framework
the library authors won't care if any
users are opening open using open
telemetry or not they can implement the
api and collect um or put the hooks in
to collect the telemetry information
using the api
and if the end user is not actually
collecting the open telemetry data from
this library or framework it will not
have any overhead and they won't need to
distribute a instrumented version of
their library or framework in a
non-instrumented version of their
library framework this is completely
transparent whether you're using or not
using uh or not collecting the open
telemetry data from this library or
framework
and it's zero overhead if the user does
not email open telemetry uh in their
application and it provides very strict
stability guarantees so the library
authors and framework authors
they won't need to be concerned about
well is this api going to be changing is
it going to break things um it provides
a very very stable and strict guarantee
to these librarian framework authors to
kind of ease their concerns about
affecting their uh library or framework
the sda the sdk piece was intentionally
um decoupled from the api piece so
they're separate packages on every
single language
and the purpose is to make sure that the
api is super stable and the sdk can
evolve and
change
in a
quicker fashion as needed uh where it's
user-facing
interfaces so
um
every major major language this is
intended to be used by the end users in
your applications that then serve your
users right
and you can enable the open telemetry
data collection using the sdk um and
start consuming the open telemetry data
emitted from any of the
libraries that you use
you use the sdk to set configuration
options for what gets collected what
processing is applied after the
collection and where the metrics are
sent
and i just discussed that it was
intentionally decoupled from the api for
stability guarantees and dependency
flexibility
and all languages with an open telemetry
sdk can send data via otlp natively so
that's an important part
um if you're using open telemetry within
your application and you set the sdk up
to gather this open telemetry data
you don't need the collector piece uh
the separate collector binary piece
of open telemetry in order to send this
data somewhere
so that makes this collector
portion of open telemetry optional
but the open telemetry collector is an
application written in go that receives
open filament data from end user
applications
and it can use plugable modules to
further process
the payloads such as making
metric generation
doing aggregations uh applying
transforms or rate limiting and etc
and it sends the data again it can send
it upstream to another collector or it
can submit the data to uh for further
processing
or to data stores to sas providers like
scout
so where does that leave scout
with the observability piece in mind and
what's our roadmap for 2022
so the scout product roadmap for 2022 is
transforming from application
performance monitoring to application
performance observability and eventually
into full stack observability
in q4 of 2021 we released the external
services feature of scout that allows
you to understand and monitor requests
to external services um through http api
calls to third parties or each other
microservices that starts to get that
a bit of that observability piece as far
as the external services go within the
existing scout platform
last year we actually started building a
new platform
specifically geared towards being able
to do the application performance
observability um
uh
utilizing open telemetry in 2022 so
we're expanding from application forms
manage monitoring to application
performance observability
being able to
ingest
high
um
just gigantic amounts of of traces trace
data from applications in order to
provide that observability
uh piece with all of that contextual
information
gathered from open telemetry
instrumentation and allow you to see
insights into your application
based on that data
and then later this year we're going to
move beyond application performance
observability into full stack
observability things like logging and
events will
be able to hook up and gather this open
telemetry data in from further
systems not just applications but um
systems in infrastructure that emits
open telemetry metrics logs
and even traces outside of
the
traditionally atm uh applications that
we've so far um focused on
and then as early 1.0 by the end of this
year um we
have a very aggressive timeline of
becoming out of beta by the end of this
year
so open telemetry how it's changing data
collection and scout um
so
right now the open telemetry
or the scout agent sits in your
application and it's an in-process
thread that collects telemetry data from
the instrumentation that we've written
ourselves
um it collects metrics for every single
transaction
uh and sends that to scout
and then in addition to those aggregated
metrics it picks out interesting traces
detailed traces that are selected from
an algorithm that um give you some
insight uh the starting's the the
beginning of some observability within
your application to what may be slow or
where the pain points of your users may
be
but the the difference between
the way the scout agent works now and
that they shift to open telemetry is now
with open telemetry the open telemetry
instrumentation will sit within your
application and traces of every single
transaction will be sent to step up and
scouts
value add and what we need to surface
for for application performance
observability lies in
what what insights and what we can
automatically
provide to your developers or your
performance
um uh engineers
about your applications without
overloading you uh or requiring you to
build any dashboards to get those
insights right
so
that's gonna be the challenge of
observability in the face of just
enormous amounts of data collection
so just like the
hubble telescope
changed the observability of our
universe
open telemetry is a very large piece of
how we can enable observability within
our applications and infrastructure over
the next few years
uh what may be a
dark spot a blind spot in your
application performance now will change
with the
addition of open telemetry
so just like the hubble telescope
zooming into
a the darkest spot that we could find
from our observable galaxy
we can now see that it's not dark it's
not empty it's actually full of
these whole galaxies that are now
observable invisible um that we thought
and
never knew that were there before and we
can observe these with the modern
instrumentation
so
this is what
observability or what open telemetry is
bringing to the open um the
observability space to the monitoring
space
so open telemetry uh is a
somewhat new project uh over the last
two years and the tracing portion of
open telemetry is actually stable
and being released as stable uh within
the major languages now uh javascript
ruby java go
those languages have
have or are approaching stable releases
for the api sdk
and the
protocol open telemetry is the
timeline for metrics and logging follow
um within this this tier and early next
uh they're working on
stabilizing actually the protocol and
api for metrics is already stable uh but
the sdk is in feature freeze and now
you're starting to see development being
worked towards uh and on within these
languages for the api and the sdk for
metrics and then
after that will come longing
so that the whole of the open telemetry
uh project encompasses these uh these
three traditional pillars of uh
observability
and our development um follows the open
telemetry um
timeline very closely we're not trying
to build a vendor implementation on top
of the open telemetry uh project we're
not trying to put any shims in between
us and the open telemetry we don't want
to we want to be part of the open
telemetry um
ecosystem and the contributors to open
telemetry uh so that's available for
everybody and it's not again going from
the
walled garden of traditional atm vendors
or um logging vendors into an open
standard and then eventually you know
five or so years from now uh
migrates its way back to being walled
walled garden type thing we wanna uh
this is this open telemetry project is
super super important um and is changing
the game of uh monitoring and
observability logging all these larger
vendors
so we wanna keep it that way
so what does this mean if you're a
current scout customer um
it means the choice is yours um
you can remain on the existing stat apm
product and we will continue to support
and improve our uh existing scout
platform in 2022 and beyond
you can choose to go hybrid
you can have your existing applications
remain on scout apm and put any new
applications that you hook up to scout
on the observability platform or you
know you can mix and match your use
cases as desired
the great thing is you can run both the
existing scout agent and the open
telemetry uh instrumentation side by
side uh so you can even run both at the
same time and you can time it to happen
when you want it can be intermittent
incremental to switch over as our new
platform becomes more mature
and adds features um for for things that
you're already getting in the scout
platform
so
uh in conclusion kind of the
observability is coming soon to a
theater near you
if you want to learn more about
observability within scout
uh sign up for our newsletter it's
atm.com observability and you can stay
informed uh opt into the beta of the new
platform
um and just
stay up to date with uh scout's
evolution into application performance
observability and eventually full stack
observability
through this newsletter